the first woman to file a criminal
complaint against new york governor
andrew cuomo
is telling us why she did it in an
exclusive interview with cbs this
morning
in albany's times union newspaper
brittany comisso
says cuomo groped and sexually harassed
her
kamisso was identified as executive
assistant number one in the state
attorney general's report
and is one of 11 women who accuse the
governor of sexual misconduct
cuomo denies all their allegations
commisso says the governor broke the law
and in her words needs to be held
accountable
to me this was a dream job and it
unfortunately turned into a nightmare
thirty-two-year-old brittany camiso
started working as an executive
assistant in new york governor andrew
cuomo's office in 2017.
nearly four years later she's the woman
known as executive assistant number one
in the new york attorney general's
report and to allegations of sexual
harassment by the governor
in the report you're known as executive
assistant number one
i am executive assistant in the
governor's office
but i am also a mother i am a daughter
i am a friend i'm a colleague
i am more than executive assistant
number one
she says governor cuomo groped her twice
the first time on new year's eve
december 31st
2019 at the governor's mansion
i had to go over to the mansion to help
the governor with
a state of the state speech i wasn't
there late
i did my final edit and while i was
upstairs in the office the governor said
why don't we take a selfie so his
suggestion
yes with your phone with my phone
i then felt while taking the selfie
his hand go down my back onto my butt
and he started rubbing it not sliding it
not you know quickly brushing over it
rubbing my butt and did you
ask him what are you doing well this was
while i was taking the selfie i became
so nervous that my hands were clearly
shaking
and a lot of the photos that i was
snapping
were completely blurry i showed him them
and he said oh you know those aren't
you know those aren't good and he said
why don't we go sit on the couch
and we can take a better one so you sit
on the couch um i sat on the couch
because i thought to myself
okay i don't think on the couch that he
would have a way
to just do what he just did so i felt
safer
actually on the couch and in the photo
you know i have my arm wrapped around
his shoulder
you know almost as if you know we were
taking a picture with
a buddy and that is the one that has
been blurred out
that has been now released to the public
the governor has denied that he put his
hand on commisso's bottom
during the selfie commisso alleges that
the governor groped her
a second time at the governor's mansion
in november of 2020.
so he gets up and he goes to give me a
hug
and i could tell immediately when he
hugged me it was in a
probably the most sexually
aggressive manner than any of the other
hugs
that he had given me um it was then that
i said
you know uh governor you know my words
were you're going to get us in trouble
and i thought to myself that probably
wasn't
the best thing to say but at that time
i was so afraid that one of the mansion
staff
that they were going to come up and see
this
and think oh you know is that what she
comes here for
and that's not what i came there for and
that's not who i am
and i was terrified of that and when i
said that
he walked over shut the door
so hard to the point where i thought for
sure
someone downstairs must think they must
think if they heard that what is going
on
came back to me and that's when he put
his hand up my blouse
and cupped my breast over my bra i
exactly remember looking down
seeing his hand which is a large hand
thinking to myself oh my
god this is happening
it happened so quick he didn't say
anything
when i stopped it he just pulled away
and
walked away i want to read to you what
the governor said quote to touch a
woman's breast
who i hardly know in the mansion
with 10 staff around with my family in
the mansion
to say i don't care who sees us i would
have to lose my mind to do such a thing
reading that is disgusting it's simple
i know the truth he knows the truth
i know what happened and so does he for
more than three months she says she
didn't tell
anyone until she watched governor
cuomo's press conference
on march 3. but this is what i want you
to know and i want you to know this from
me directly
he almost has this smirk
that he thinks that he's untouchable
that was the tipping point
i broke down you know i said he's lying
i felt like he was personally saying it
to me
i never touched anyone
inappropriately yes you did yes you have
and not only yes but one of them is me
and that's when i i broke down i told my
coworkers
a little bit and there were two people
you told us to at the time
yes why did you file that criminal
complaint with the sheriff's office
because it was the right thing to do the
governor needs to be held accountable
being held accountable to you means
seeing the governor
charged with the crime what he did to me
was a crime he broke the law
camiso says she's thankful to the other
accusers
for giving her the strength to come
forward there was a time when
it between my personal life and this it
was too much
people don't understand you know it's
the governor of the state of new york
he is a professional fighter and i think
people should know
that it hasn't been easy and
i apologize that i haven't come forward
sooner
kamisso doesn't remember the exact date
the governor allegedly grabbed her
breast
something cuomo's attorney pointed out
in a recent news conference cbs news has
asked cuomo's legal team for a list of
visitors to the governor's mansion
from october through december of 2020.
cuomo's personal attorney rita glavin
also says the governor did not
grope or sexually assault commisso and
questions the fairness of the state ag's
report claiming it omitted evidence
that was favorable to the governor so
this is a classic case of
he said she said but she is standing by
everything that you heard in that
interview you know the fact that uh
melissa de rosa
who was the number one chief aide to the
governor
has decided based on the reporting that
you and the albany times union has done
in other words i can sort of see that it
happened late sunday night after
we'd released a couple of sound bites
from your interview
clearly signifies that she can no longer
stand by the governor's side and so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
in the assembly
and i think it's actually more now than
uh he said she said because he hasn't
said all that much
we've waited for more of a response to
the ag's report yeah and she said quite
a lot to you she did i mean but
he continues to say that didn't happen
his personal attorney over the weekend
did a 45-minute interview on another
network and
basically said it's not true and that
based on the
report which we have right here all 165
pages
that there were questions um but there's
no question about what britney comisso
says happened to her she's very clear
about that
and from the interview you just did i
think you can see why the new york
attorney general
said that these were credible reports
and you really understand the
predicament
that if the allegations are true the
governor would put people
in he's got so much power they are
employees of the state and of him
when she says you're going to get us in
trouble that line really rings true
and now you've got everybody from the
president of the united states on down
to
the democrats in here in new york state
that's right that are saying
extraordinary situation well you can see
more of our interview on paramount plus
and cbsnews.com and the instadoc
executive assistant number one cuomo
accuser
speaks